الصوت المرعب
للقصف المستمر، القذائف الإسرائيلية تضرب
أهدافًا أقرب فأقرب إلى هذه المدرسة التي تديرها الأمم المتحدة
في وسط غزة للآلاف الذين
يحتمون هنا، حان الوقت للانتقال مرة أخرى
للعائلات التي أجبرت على الفرار للنجاة بحياتها،
وهذه ليست المرة الأولى أو حتى الثانية
للكثيرين مرة واحدة  لقد حملوا مرة أخرى
أشلاء حياتهم التي مزقتها الحرب
بحثًا عن الأمان بعيد المنال قبل أيام فقط، وقد
تعهد الكثيرون هنا بأنهم لن
يتحركوا أبدًا مرة أخرى أبدًا، وهم
على استعداد الآن للكسر فقط لأنهم يعرفون أن
حياة أطفالهم على
المحك في كل مكان آخر مزدحم
ليس هناك ما يضمن أنهم سيجدون مكانًا ولكن
ماذا يمكنهم
فعله حتى لو لم يكن لديهم مكان آخر يذهبون إليه،
لا يمكنهم البقاء هنا، لا يريدون أن
يموتوا هنا، المشهد هو تذكير قاتم
لما عاناه آباؤهم وأجدادهم
1948 عندما أخرجتهم الميليشيات الصهيونية
من
مسقط رأسهم في برد الشتاء والبطانيات والفرش ثمينة
وسيارات السلع والوقود الذي يشغلها شحيح
ومن لا يستطيع استئجار
عربات تجرها الحمير أما الباقي فهي رحلة طويلة سيرا على
الأقدام إلى
الوجهة  بالنسبة للعديد من أقاربهم، فإن المنازل
سقف فوق رؤوسهم حتى لو كانوا
في أحياء دمرتها الغارات
الجوية الإسرائيلية بالفعل،
معارك الشوارع تحتدم في جميع أنحاء
غزة، مما يحول المناطق شمال وجنوب
القطاع إلى مدن أشباح، وندوب
المعركة
الخام، نحن في حرب متعددة الساحات  نحن
نتعرض للهجوم من سبعة
قطاعات مختلفة: غزة، لبنان، سوريا، يهودا والسامرة،
العراق، اليمن، وإيران. أي شخص
يعمل ضدنا هو هدف محتمل.
لا توجد حصانة لأي
شخص. حلفاء إيران في المنطقة
يشاركون في أعمال عدائية منخفضة المستوى
ردًا على ما يقولونه لإسرائيل.  الحرب في
غزة: الحوثيون اليمنيون يهاجمون
السفن التي يزعمون أنها تابعة لإسرائيل، مما
يحول البحر الأحمر إلى
طريق خطير للتجارة العالمية تعهد إيران
بالانتقام لمقتل
قائد إيراني في سوريا، مما أثار
مخاوف متجددة من توسيع
الصراع خاصة على
المدفعية الحدودية اللبنانية الإسرائيلية  إطلاق نار مع
دعم إيراني، أدى حزب الله إلى إبقاء
البلدين على حافة الهاوية منذ 8 تشرين الأول/أكتوبر،
في غزة: سباق من أجل البقاء بين
روتين
الضربات الجوية التي تسرع إلى المستشفيات والمدافن،
والبحث المستمر عن الغذاء
والماء والبحث عن مأوى لما يقرب
من مليوني شخص
النازحين سوف ريبلي سي إن إن تل
أبيب